foreign
we are in the early stages of baby step
two
my question revolves around purchasing a
van to go live down by the river
sounds like we got Bill Shakespeare on
the line what's so I know where does
this uh where does this idea come from
right after the pandemic started I did
purchase a van and I did a build out on
it did a lot of traveling while working
a desk job and it was wonderful and I
would like to do that again and purchase
another vehicle
but I thought the virtual flap from Dave
when I decided that that would be step
3B versus making a down payment on the
house
so I need to have some advice from you
on where in 456 you would place this
purchase and what type of margin I
should be putting against it versus
investing
okay so I just want to clarify though
that you will you will have a primary
residence this is just this is the
resonance this is the residence yeah
that was the virtual slop that I got
from Dave
um I did want to purchase the van before
purchasing Sticks and Bricks
but after doing some research I do see
the value
of making a home purchase so that is now
in the financial plan and goal set so
you'll do that first and then you're
asking about the van
and then I'm asking about the van
what does the van get you like is it
gets you Freedom does it get you
um flexibility what is that are you just
like camping a lot well the van um I
work remote
so the van will bring me the opportunity
to travel and see the country I do have
friends and family scattered all over
the United States that I did frequent it
also is an opportunity for me to explore
other cities
eventually I would like to relocate out
of my geographical area
okay and I'd like to research behind
that so it's a it's a recreation it's a
toy basically yeah
um yeah okay yeah that's great or do you
have family Sonia are you married kids
no I'm single I have four children
they're all adults okay okay that's
great so Rachel stop me if I'm wrong
here Sonia if you said for 36 months for
three years I'm going to go see the
country and I'm going to live this way
and I'm gonna do all this with cash I I
wouldn't necessarily have a problem with
it
awesome and you said I want to move to a
new town I want to explore some cities
that I might want to relocate in and
live permanently like that I mean Rachel
tell me I'm wrong that that doesn't I
don't think you have to have a house and
then go do that
what we don't want you to do is to look
up and be 55 years old or 60 years old
and you've got no equity you've got no
place
like no pun intended to park and say
this is this is my home all you have is
a completely depreciated out van with
500 000 miles on it that's what we want
to avoid yeah so how old are you Sonya
and I had that weekend
wake up I turned 50 last September woke
up and decided I don't want to have to
work into retirement and I don't have
the financial footing to avoid that
right now so and where are you at did
you say
what was that where are you at in the
baby steps are you baby step two still
paying off debt
I'm paying off debt my debt-free date
will be essentially Christmas this year
oh good congratulations okay so yeah so
I think my goals would be and where are
you living now
I'm currently in the Upper Midwest I
mean like like uh look like are you at
home you're renting okay perfect no
you're great you're great
okay yeah so Sonia I think mine would be
yeah get to Christmas pay off that debt
uh look to get that emergency fund and
maybe step three and then I would look
to purchase yes some type of real estate
I think that will be really wise
um and to have that to your name to
John's points and again it can be
a town home it could be a condo it
doesn't have to be anything big and
fancy but that there's something a place
to go to that you have
and then I would be focused on
retirement then after that because I
want you to be able to retire right and
actually have money to live off of so
starting that process and then once
that's going
um and again you're you're 50 years old
so you know there can be some ketchup
retirement that you can do when it gets
to that point but again run those
numbers I want that to be a priority for
you
um and then at the same time you can be
saving simultaneously then for a
purchase of a van you know and in the
meantime Sonia I mean you know while
you're espec not while you're getting
out of debt not emergency fund but
beyond that I would be okay while you're
saving up
um for a down payment to rent something
for two weeks if you want you know what
I mean like you can still enjoy your
life after baby step three
um but I I would
focus on though saving up a down payment
because by that time frame
um you're going to be two years probably
from now and I want you to be able to
know kind of like you're saying where
you want to be where you want to settle
and and start looking for a home
total sense
does that give you peace or does that
give you angst
um a little of both to be honest
um you know after realizing where I was
and August is going to quote it as
drinking the Kool-Aid of Dave Ramsey I
got really scared and got very serious I
took on a second job good for you about
80 hours a week how much do you make a
year Sonia
my core job is 75k and my side hustle is
about 35 000. wow yeah good for you so
can I tell you something hard to hear
yeah
um and this is like the worst part of my
job is like the
the bearer of reality okay
my guess is looking back you've been
through the mill huh you've been through
it um I've been yeah married in divorced
three times every type of Life situation
has hit so you've been through it
and you've reached a point where you
have some sort of equilibrium and for
the first time possibly ever you've got
peace
and I'm going to tell you I would wait
24 months maybe even 36 months before I
started doing a ton of traveling I would
love to see you just buckle down until
you're 53 years old and make a hundred
thousand dollars on top of a hundred
thousand dollars on top of a hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars and get some
Financial margin in your life before you
hit the road and visit friends and
travel
you've been through hell and back and
you've got to give yourself a cushion a
cushion Foundation under you never had
yeah so I would hold off on traveling I
would start sucking away money and then
you're going to be able to have a Freer
55 and 60.